[Music]
good morning Hank it's Friday yes hey
can you guess why I'm doing my happy
dance it's not because I no longer have
to toil under the oppressive weight of
my own hair although that is nice and
it's not because it's Friday although
I'm psyched about that - it's because
noted American nerdfighter Al Gore just
won half the Nobel Prize for his work on
climate change yes I mean Hank if I
could have picked anyone in the entire
world to win the Nobel Peace Prize it
would actually actually would have been
us it would have been you and me and we
would have won it for spearheading the
nerdfighter movement that led to the
complete end of global conflict but if I
could have picked anyone else to win the
Nobel Peace Prize it would have
definitely been actually no that that
would have been Oprah my second pick
would have been Oprah but my third pick
would have totally been Al Gore hang in
honor of Al Gore's Nobel Peace Prize I'm
going to propose that you and I and our
feud and instead of feuding go back to
the real business of brotherhood 2.0
which is decreasing worldsuck
specifically by recarbanation
brotherhood 2.0 hank as you probably
remember way back in April when the
videos have been viewed a lot fewer
times than they have now I donated 2.5
to carbon fun org to neutralize our
carbon output but since then our carbon
output has gone up pretty considerably
now Hank remember I'm not very good at
math so I apologize in advance if I get
any of this wrong according to YouTube
our videos have been viewed three
million thirty thousand three hundred
and thirty seven times Wow now Hank I'm
gonna say for the sake of simplicity
that our average video is about three
minutes long in point of fact it's a
little bit longer but let's face it not
everybody watches till the end so we're
just gonna say three minutes that means
that 9 million 90 1111 minutes have been
devoted to watching Brotherhood 2.0
that's more than 150 1516 hours and more
than six thousand three hundred and
thirteen days Hank I know this is hard
to believe but trust me I'm not making
it up in total people have spent more
than 17 years watching Brotherhood 2.0
but Hank in fact people have spent even
more than 150 1516 hours with
Brotherhood 2.0 because we also have to
count the amount of time they spend
commenting we've had a total of more
than 17 thousand comments on
to command more than 30,000 comments on
YouTube Hank for the sake of simplicity
I'm going to assume that it takes about
one minute on average to write each
comment now I know that it takes more
than a minute to write a truly
nerdfighter ly comment but it takes much
less than a minute to just repost spam
which let's face it comprises about 30
percent of YouTube's total commenting
and you also have to count all the
action that's going on in my past the
Brotherhood to comm forum Hank there
have been more than 116,000 posts in my
pants so if you add all that stuff up
from the commenting and the stuff going
on in my pants and the viewing of the
actual videos you get hold on I have to
look up the number 154 thousand two
hundred forty-four hours the average
computer takes about point 1 1 kilowatts
per hour to browse the internet so that
means that you have to multiply that
huge number that I just mentioned times
0.1 1 which equals sixteen thousand 966
kilowatts now it takes an average of one
point three five pounds of carbon in the
United States to make one kilowatt of
energy so that means that I have to
multiply that previous number by one
point three five which equals twenty two
thousand nine hundred five pounds of
carbon Hank that means that Brotherhood
2.0 as a videoblog has created more
carbon in the last nine and a half
months than the average Dutch person
creates in an entire year
holy crap Hank we've created a carbon
monster man Hank I really wish I was one
of those people who believes deep down
inside their hearts that they're
non-sustainable lifestyle is a right and
not a privilege and that therefore
global warming can't exist but I'm not
one of those people Hank I'm a
nerdfighter and that's why I'm spending
$63 at carbonfund.org to offset
Brotherhood 2.0 carbon emissions Hank
I'd like to thank both Al Gore and you
for helping me to understand the
environmental emergency that we're all
facing I'll see you on Monday by the way
global warming skeptics I have a message
for you bye beachfront property and call
me in 50 years